the Joe Rogan experience it's such a
crazy leap that you've made I mean
people know you as much now for your
films as they do for your music yeah
pretty much especially well I've really
noticed that would not be like in an
elevator like the music fans I can
pretty much spot them you know but like
when some guy comes up to me an elevator
looks like he's a lawyer or something
which I I have to get to grips with out
cuz I'm not you know I'm old every time
a cop comes up they're like what is this
guy why don't I go he's like a fan
because he's 30 years younger than me
well I get when normal people I go ma'am
so into this or that because you know I
figured like you know heavy-metal music
is very specific but everybody likes
movies right yeah yeah I can pretty much
spot them what do you look for metal
feel like what what do you see it like
what's coming your way
well it's change but now it's always a
guy with a shaved head and the long
goatee
that's very nobody has yeah nobody has
hair anymore it's like I swear sometimes
of on stage the longer that's funny yeah
right that was rock and roll synonymous
yeah it's like not not anymore what made
you make that leap in horror films well
I always wanted to make movies that was
always my main goal in life
really before music well it was well let
me back it up I loved everything equally
but as a kid it all seemed unattainable
so it was all of a fantasy like oh yeah
I'm gonna go to Hollywood make movies oh
yeah I'm gonna have a band like no
you're not you're just living in some
crap town you're gonna do nothing is
what it felt like up in Haverhill yeah
yeah you're on the Newton never Falls
yes so fine I think when I was a kid and
played ice hockey we would play against
and I'm sure like 30 seconds 30 seconds
I'm saying oh yeah you know growing up I
mean it's like you can have a crappy
band in the garage with your friends but
it's not gonna do things and then we had
a super 8 camera so we'd make crappy
super 8 movies but none of it seemed
realistic I thought my life was going to
be you know world's worst bike messenger
New York City that seemed to be what I
was destined for but
then as the band started taking off and
which seemed odd in its own and there
was a chance to make music videos like
[ __ ] it I'm directing these music videos
this will be film school for me and
that's what it's what it became did you
have this thing that a lot of people
have when things start going well for
them you have sort of like impostor
syndrome like you kind of you like is
this what the [ __ ] are they gonna find
out oh yeah my whole life is like yeah
fooled them again I think everybody
feels like that I think so too
I mean I cuz I was always so I was so
shy and if I was so shy I wouldn't even
like want to talk to people on the phone
when I was a kid because that was too
much yeah
that one day I realized I just this is
how I realized it one day like in in
high school I didn't associate with
anyone like no one remembers me because
I was just invisible but me and my
friends were sort of like into punk rock
like in a place where like no one knew
what that was though and then the day we
graduated we were at like hanging out
around McDonald's and the main [ __ ]
jock kid came up who would be the worst
your worst enemy or something like hey
man goon College who do you guys get
like your cool clothes and stuff like it
was four years of torture from you your
douchebag friends and now that the day
we graduate like hey you guys so that's
what I knew everyone's so [ __ ]
insecure it doesn't matter and then the
next day I was like I don't care anymore
oh that's crime a different person yeah
it's all forgive those people you know
the people that [ __ ] with you in high
school it's hard to let that go and
realize though they just were to
probably torch it at home well you can't
let it go because that's your motivation
I'm always motivated by probably by
anger and revenge and things of that
nature that's why when people want
anti-bullying I don't know might be anti
success later on a life because you know
people to get [ __ ] with tend to make
it yeah Chris Rock has a bit about that
yeah it's true I mean certainly true for
fighters almost all the best fighters in
the UFC have some story where someone
was [ __ ] with them and they're young
and they know how to figure out how to
fight yep what's the first thing way
I'll do take karate lessons yeah believe
it Chris Rock's bit involves Steve Jobs
and a lot of other people I do not want
Microsoft like ya know
it's super true it is super true and
it's also sits interesting that you said
that you were you had social anxiety so
many people that become entertainers
also had some form of social anxiety
when they're young yeah I had to do this
thing last no the night before last I
was presenting this award to somebody at
this event and you know I'm picturing
how the stage will be really big and
high you know I can get up there it's
super impersonal doesn't matter and I
get there the stage is like lower than
this desk and it's like all the tables
with people eating dinner right they're
like oh man's nightmare I can't do this
yeah you know cuz you have to sort of be
normal
I used to freak out when I had to talk
to bank tellers I used to like you know
you're in the line doesn't make no sense
right but the line of like I'd have to
deposit my cheque and I'd be in the line
I'm like four more people and I got to
talk morley know that feeling I was like
that about every I like that was my own
not my family that lived in the house
but like an uncle came over I can't do a
deal and target Uncle Bill
upstairs call me when he leaves yeah and
then it's crazy that a guy like you
winds up singing in front of [ __ ]
thousands of people playing guitar in
front of thousands of people I wish I
could play guitar but I will sing in
front of people um it doesn't bother me
it does matter like oh it's a festival
it's a hundred thousand people I'm like
who gives a crap it's crazy so it's two
people out they don't want to say hi oh
my god that's weird
yeah especially if they're right in
front of you like the one of the
weirdest shows that any comic ever has
to do is shows where there's a really
tiny audience like the Comedy Store at
one o'clock in the morning and there's
like five people that's brutal
it's just so weird it's like 500 people
no problem
yeah five people uh that's why starting
like when which people like ah do you
ever go back and play clubs and more
intimate saying like no no I want the
shows to be bigger is in its impersonal
as humanly possible because I hated
playing clubs and the people like right
in front of you like you know yeah like
I know we do kind of suck the key just
go with it
take a break man you know let us get our
feet
[Applause]